hi hi everybody hi drew
i am so excited to meet you you're my
teenage crush
like i'm psyched that i'm sitting in
front of you right now
i i have loved you at first sight
but i love your book
so yeah i don't understand how much that
means to me thank you
and there's like all the detail is there
you bring
us in with you i mean i'm at the part
where you and nick are like
fully dating and it's just i mean i'm
like oh my gosh
it's so romantic you've lived
such an extraordinary life i mean it's
hard to pick which facet of your life i
i get to talk to you about i love the
anomaly hair care line and the whole
campaign
oh thank you i'm so proud of it
it's so joyful so sexy so beautiful i
love the wet hair the photography the
lighting
the setting i just i feel like i want to
transport myself right there
and hair care is such a you know sort of
feeling as well right when you're
washing your hair in the shower
it's like especially when you have
longer hair
it's a moment like it takes us time you
know and it's like
it's an experience and it should feel
personal and
you know like a moment of having me time
i think
um hence the campaign being wet hair and
not like perfectly blow-dried curls that
you usually see
that's what really spoke to me as i felt
like i hadn't seen anything like this
and to do something original in this
world is no easy feat
right congratulations
thank you so much i mean 60 million
followers on instagram
biggest star in india huge here
really famous husband it's a very big
life
and i'm always fascinated to learn how
people
manage their busy busy lives so would
you possibly indulge me in a breakdown
in a day in priyagka chopra jonas's
life i mean if i may say you might know
this
obviously because you've done this for
um quite a long time as well but
it's it changes with whatever job it is
right so i can take you through like
one day at the moment let's go through
today this is 24 hours
of this moment in priyanka's life here
we go
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
um okay let's see the first one here we
go
it's 8 am well i hate 8 am usually
because i'm a night person i'm not a
morning person but i have to start with
a coffee and
i actually may or may not have an
espresso machine in my room right across
my bed
so that's the first button that i press
i get up and
do the next thing that everyone does
check twitter and instagram
i believe that's coming up next let's
see the next timeline
8 15.
look at that little cutie that's my
niece krishna
um but whenever she's around me she
loves checking out my phone but you know
that's where i get my news from
twitter instagram just like everyone
else funny story but my movie the white
tiger which is out on netflix right now
i read about the fact that it was being
adapted from the book
into the movie on twitter at a time like
this
and i got my agents to call the
producers and offer my services
and chased after the movie but it
happened because of this
so it's pretty useful i also saw that
you read like time and national
geographic
some you know michelle obama you're very
intelligent and you're right like the
more informed you are
the more proactive of a life you're
gonna have and
totally i also do follow like baby
videos and dogs what's your guilty
pleasure
is fun i love tick-tock for hours before
i go to bed and suddenly it's like 4am
and i'm like
okay next timeline okay what do we do
after oh 8 30.
um yeah i usually do my days these days
um are starting with a workout because
i'm training for a tv show that i'm
doing for amazon called citadel
and this looks like nick is getting a
workout as well
well you know this was one of those
mistakes that i made where i tried to
compete with nick
um right at the beginning of me starting
to work out was during quarantine
and he was like babe come on we'll do it
we'll do it together it'll be a couple's
thing
and i was like okay i've never done that
with him before and
we start working out and i'm competitive
as hell so i'm trying to keep up to like
the 255th
squat or something and it ended like
that because i was like i could be your
weight but i can't compare
compared to you this is crazy um so then
we decided not to work out together it
just didn't work out
i love it my daughter always comes in
and gets on my back
when i'm working out and it's like she's
like goat yoga but with a human
okay next timeline
9 30 to 11 30. yeah i usually get to
work at the moment because of the book
there's a lot of book signing or
you know there's a lot of zoom calls
interviews meetings
um and i'm doing multiple time zones
because the book is launching in four
different
um territories which is the uk australia
india us so canada
so because of that i start really early
in the morning because
australia is awake at that time and then
it goes into the uk because i'm in
london here
and then it goes into america because
and then i stay up at night so it's kind
of insane right now
okay next timeline here we go noonish
one-ish
um that's when i do brunch usually uh i
try and have
two meals a day um like two good meals a
day and keeps me feeling really
energetic um and then hopefully a nap
a try or at least like a rest even if
you like
take a second lie down or read a book or
just decompress with something you know
i was knitting the other day my mom
started knitting so i like
started knitting with her i made a
sleeve and then left it so i told nick
that
he has a sleeve now the rest of the
sweater will take the rest of the year
um but you know just something which is
sort of meditation
to me at least never doesn't necessarily
always mean
you know silence and meditation in the
right route your meditation can be
whatever it is i think it's just resting
your mind from
the world pulling you apart in different
[Music]
directions